another issue that we tripped over as we
try to understand what is going to
happen or is not going to happen with
the new procedure for replay review of
pass interference the concept of the
catchable and uncatchable pass the
motion that we see from the officials to
justify a decision not to throw a flag
even if the Nickell robbie Coleman's of
the world wipeout the Tommy Lee Lewis is
the world if the ball is 15 feet over
the receivers head it doesn't matter
it's not a foul Kris and and and that's
going to be a fascinating exercise in
how they go about determining what is
and isn't catchable based upon replay
review I think generally speaking is
going to be very hard to do because look
unless you're down there on the field
you can't tell what's catchable or not
catchable that may be the element of the
judgment that gets exercised by
officials that our River Run will be
very averse to overturning yeah I think
so I mean that's something one that yes
it's gonna be hard for al River on to
make those type of calls you know on
Park Ave in New York City yeah that is
something where he's gonna have to lean
on the people like you said the
officials on the field and have some
dialogue or conversation about what they
felt you know real-time and now that
they've had a few seconds to process it
were they right you know I
yes that's gonna be interesting to see
how that goes I hope that's not too much
part of the discussion but either way
yeah I mean Al's not gonna be able to
figure everything out just because this
is reviewable now there's gonna have to
be some combo with the officials and
trying to get that particular part of
this p.i review get it right and here's
where it's going to become critical in
how they formulate the ruling on the
field if the ruling on the field is
there was illegal contact there was a
shove before the ball arrived but the
pass was uncatchable right to overturn
the ruling of no interference you've got
to determine beyond all doubt clear and
obvious evidence indisputable visual
evidence 50 drunks in a bar that it was
catchable that's the key if that's how
specific and granular they are when they
communicate to the league office what
the ruling was it's not just no pass
inter
farrance there was you know we're
claiming there was no shop no there was
a shove but the ball is uncatchable and
if it's harder to overturn on that
standard it's gonna be harder to
overturn defensive pass interference
which again should make the defensive
players yes even happier I hope I made
sense with that but I think that's the
kind of precision that we're going to
need so we know exactly what Al Revere
on is overturning or not overturn are
they gonna even do it you know is that
gonna be part of the guidelines am i
wrong that I miss something I mean that
wouldn't it be well I know you think you
would they have no guidelines it's one
sentence pass interference is now
subject to replay review a period
they've done nothing more with it and
maybe this means they need to do more
with it in may yeah they did make
sausage in one day right but but did
this whole catchable and an uncatchable
pass that that is going to be I think a
major factor especially if the officials
realize look if I don't think it's pass
interference all I have to say is the
pass is uncatchable and our River runs
not gonna overturn me and they'll have
to worry about him agreeing with whether
or not I think there was a shove or no
shove on a catchable ball I just say it
was uncatchable and good luck
overturning that algorithm yeah that's
gonna be where it's very tricky right so
yeah I am interested to see some of the
language maybe when it becomes an
official thing here and maybe just
because yeah that's gonna be tough to
dictate all that I don't even know what
I want to say because it's such a deep
deep subject there but yeah I almost
want to say maybe that part of it
shouldn't be reviewable like to a degree
if it's ruled uncatchable that's
uncatchable that's all right then that's
your safe harbor any pass interference
if you don't want it to be reviewed by
our River on you say every one of them
is well then you say it's if it's
uncatchable it's not pass interference
but if you want to conclude it wasn't
pass interference you just say it's
uncatchable right exactly right you know
in a deeper question here really Mike
are you a sausage patty guy or sausage
links links Man patties are gross what
patties are gross they're gross I'd
rather have my my mystery meat packed in
in an animal's intestine any day of the
week but that's oh that's gross that's
grosser than the other packed into the
beans I'm being sarcastic
ok sausage patty looks too much like a
hamburger okay to me it's only a sausage
if it's you know
shaped like a sausage okay like a link
I'm a pot I'm a paddy guy I'm a paddy
guy okay well wait a minute did wheat
sausage at breakfast this we don't know
you were a big well you're making eggs
I mean I'll eat the links but if you
gave me a choice I'd rather have the
patties that's all I'm saying I don't
like there's something I don't trust a
sausage patty I don't know why oh yes
don't they're too small then oh I'm just
not a big fan all right that was a very
important thing that we've resolved
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports